right that's got to be something really
exciting yeah i mean honestly i have no
idea how i got into this position
but he's like generally like the
sweetest person i've ever met
and that's like everything i i would
like is like meet idols who are just as
incredible in real life and even better
and he's been like now such a mentor to
me and just like a friend and has been
really amazing so i'm really excited to
go for it'll be it'll be crazy and
tate's reaching a crazy level of success
as well currently headlining her own
north american tour while her breakout
hit you broke me first has racked up
over one billion streams
[Music]
do you go oh man i gotta i gotta do
something that does that again
yeah the pressure definitely is there
once you've
experienced a certain level of something
i think and that's just honestly just
like your own expectations that you put
on yourself because i'm like i want to
constantly do better and i want to write
something better i want to write
something new i don't want to do that
again speaking of something new tate's
debut album i used to think i could fly
is set to drop may
[Music]
i 27 people to know like what i can do i
think that my album literally has like
10 million genres like that's the sound
trying to experiment as much as possible
because there's so much music out there
right now like it's honestly trying to
just like push yourself as an artist
[Music]